when did you fall in love with
programming first
well it's pretty uh pretty young age
actually so um
you know i started off uh actually games
was my first love so starting to play
chess when i was around four years old
and then um it was actually with
winnings from a chess competition that i
managed to buy my first chess computer
when i was about eight years old it was
a zx spectrum which was hugely popular
in the uk at the time
and uh it's amazing machine because i
think it trained a whole generation of
programmers in the uk because it was so
accessible you know you literally
switched it on and there was the basic
prompt and you could just get going and
um my parents didn't really know
anything about computers so but because
it was my money from a chess competition
i could i could say i i wanted to buy it
uh and then you know i just went to
bookstores got books on programming and
um started typing in you know the
programming code and and then of course
um once you start doing that you start
adjusting it and then making your own
games and that's when i fell in love
with computers and realized that they
were a very magical device um in a way i
kind of i don't would have been able to
explain this at the time but i felt that
there was sort of almost a magical
extension of your mind i always had this
feeling and i've always loved this about
computers that you can set them off
doing something some task for you you
can go to sleep come back the next day
and it's solved um you know that feels
magical to me so i mean all machines do
that to some extent they all enhance our
natural capabilities obviously cars make
us allow us to move faster than we can
run but this was a machine to extend the
mind
and and then of course ai is the
ultimate expression of what a machine
may be able to do or learn so um very
naturally for me that thought extended
into into ai quite quickly remember the
the programming language
that was first
started yes
spectrum i don't know what specific form
it was and then later on i got a
commodore amiga which uh
was a fantastic machine no you're just
showing off so yeah well lots of my
friends had atari st's and i i managed
to get amigas it was a bit more powerful
and uh and that was incredible and used
to do um programming in assembler and
and uh also amos basic this this
specific form of basic it was incredible
actually as well all my coding skills
and when did you fall in love with ai so
when did you first
start to gain an understanding that you
can not just write programs that
do some mathematical operations for you
while you sleep but something that's
a keen to
bringing an entity to life
sort of
a thing that can figure out something
more complicated than a
than a simple mathematical operation
yeah so there was a few stages for me
all while i was very young so first of
all as i was trying to improve at
playing chess i was captaining various
england junior chess teams and at the
time when i was about you know maybe 10
11 years old i was gonna become a
professional chess player that was my
first
thought um that dream was there too sure
she tried to get to the highest level
yeah so i was um you know i got to when
i was about 12 years old i got to master
standard i was second highest rated play
in the world to judith polgar who
obviously ended up being an amazing
chess player and uh world women's
champion and when i was trying to
improve at chess where you know what you
do is you obviously first of all you're
trying to improve your own thinking
processes so
that leads you to thinking about
thinking how is your brain coming up
with these ideas why is it making
mistakes how can you how can you improve
that thought process but the second
thing is that you it was just the
beginning this was like in the in the
early 80s mid 80s of chess computers if
you remember they were physical balls
like the one we have in front of us and
you pressed down the you know the
squares and i think kasparov had a
branded version of it that i i got and
um you were you know used to that
they're not as strong as they are today
but they were they were pretty strong
and you used to practice against them um
to try and improve your openings and
other things and so i remember i think i
probably got my first one i was around
11 or 12. and i remember thinking um
this is amazing you know how has someone
programmed uh this this chessboard to
play chess uh and uh it was very
formative book i bought which was called
the chess computer handbook by david
levy which came out in 1984 or something
so i must have got it when i was about
11 12 and it explained fully how these
chess programs were made and i remember
my first ai program being uh programming
my amiga it couldn't it wasn't powerful
enough to play chess i couldn't write a
whole chess program but i wrote a
program for it to play othello
reversally it's sometimes called i think
in the u.s and so a slightly simpler
game than chess but i used all of the
principles that chess programs had alpha
beta search all of that and that was my
first ai program i remember that very
well i was around 12 years old so that
that that brought me into ai and then
the second part was later on uh when i
was around 1617 and i was writing games
professionally designing games uh
writing a game called theme park which
um had ai as a core gameplay component
as part of the simulation um and it sold
you know millions of copies around the
world and people loved the way that the
ai even though it was relatively simple
by today's ai standards um was was
reacting to the way you as the player
played it so it was called a sandbox
game so it's one of the first types of
games like that along with simcity and
it meant that every game you played was
unique
is there something you could say just on
a small tangent
about
really impressive ai
from a game design
human enjoyment perspective
really impressive ai that you've seen in
games and maybe what does it take to
create an ai system and how hard of a
problem is that so a million questions
yeah
just as a brief tangent
well look i think um
games uh games have been significant in
my life for three reasons so first of
all to to i was playing them and
training myself on games when i was a
kid then i went through a phase of
designing games and writing ai4 games so
all the games i i professionally wrote
uh had ai as a core component and that
was mostly in the in the 90s and the
reason i was doing that in games
industry was at the time the games
industry i think was the cutting edge of
technology so whether it was graphics
with people like john carmack and quake
and those kind of things or ai i think
actually all the action was going on in
games and and we seen we're still
reaping the benefits of that even with
things like gpus which you know i find
ironic was obviously invented for
graphics computer graphics but then
turns out to be amazingly useful for ai
it just turns out everything's a matrix
multiplication appear it appears you
know in the whole world yes so um so i
think games at the time had the most
cutting edge ai and a lot of the the
games uh uh we you know i was involved
in writing so there was a game called
black and white which was one game i was
involved with in the early stages of
which i still think is the most um
impressive uh example of reinforcement
learning in a computer game so in that
game you know you trained a little pet
animal uh and
yeah and it sort of learned from how you
were treating it so if you treated it
badly then it became mean yeah and then
it would be mean to to your villagers
and your and your population the sort of
uh the little tribe that you were
running uh but if you were kind to it
then it would be kind and people were
fascinated by how that worked and so was
i to be honest with the way it kind of
developed and um especially the mapping
to good and evil yeah it made you made
you realize made me realize that you can
sort of in the way in the choices you
make can define
uh the
where you end up and that means
all of us are capable of the good uh
evil it all matters in the different
choices along the trajectory to those
places that you make it's fascinating i
mean games can do that philosophically
to you and it's rare it seems rare yeah
well games are i think a unique medium
because um you as the player you're not
just passively consuming the the the
entertainment right you're actually
actively involved as an as a as an agent
so i think that's what makes it in some
ways can be more visceral than other
other mediums like you know films and
books so the second so that was you know
designing ai and games and then the
third use uh uh i've we've used of ai is
in deep mind from the beginning which is
using games as a testing ground for
proving out ai algorithms and developing
ai algorithms and that was a that was a
sort of um a core component of our
vision at the start of deep mind was
that we would use games very heavily uh
as our main testing ground certainly to
begin with um because it's super
efficient to use games and also you know
it's very easy to have metrics to see
how well your systems are improving and
what direction your ideas are going in
and whether you're making incremental
improvements
and because those games are often rooted
in something that humans did for a long
time beforehand there's already a strong
set of rules like it's already a damn
good benchmark yes it's really good for
so many reasons because you've got
you've got you've got clear measures of
how good humans can be at these things
and in some cases like go we've been
playing it for thousands of years um and
and uh often they have scores or at
least win conditions so it's very easy
for reward learning systems to get a
reward it's very easy to specify what
that reward is um and uh also at the end
it's easy to you know to test uh
externally you know uh how strong is
your system by of course playing against
you know the world's strongest players
at those games so it's it's so good for
so many reasons and it's also very
efficient to run potentially millions of
simulations in parallel on the cloud so
um i think there's a huge reason why we
were so successful back in you know
starting out 2010 how come we were able
to progress so quickly because we've
utilized games and um you know at the
beginning of deep mind we also hired
some amazing game engineers uh who i
knew from my previous lives in the games
industry and uh and that helped to
bootstrap us very quickly and plus it's
somehow super compelling almost at a
philosophical level
of man versus machine
over over a chessboard or a go board
and especially given that the entire
history of ai is defined by people
saying is going to be impossible to make
a machine that
beats a human being in chess
and then once that happened
people were certain when i was coming up
in ai that go
is not a game that could be solved
because of the combinatorial complexity
it's just too it's it's it's you know
no matter how much moore's law you have
compute is just never going to be able
to crack the game of go yeah and so that
then there's something compelling about
facing sort of taking on the
impossibility of that task from the
ai
researcher perspective engineer
perspective and then as a human being
just observing this whole thing
your
beliefs about what you thought was
impossible
being broken apart
it's it's uh humbling
to realize we're not as smart as we
thought
it's humbling to realize that the things
we think are impossible now perhaps will
be done
in the future there's something
really powerful about a game
ai system being a human being in a game
that drives that message
home for like millions billions of
people especially in the case of go sure
well look i think it's a i mean it has
been a fascinating journey and and
especially as i i think about it from i
can understand it from both sides both
as the ai
you know creators of the ai um but also
as a games player originally yeah so you
know it was a it was a really
interesting it was i mean it was a
fantastic um but also somewhat
bittersweet moment the alphago match for
me um uh seeing that and and and being
obviously heavily heavily involved in
that um but you know as you say chess
has been uh the i mean kasparov i think
rightly called it the drosophila of of
intelligence right so it's sort of i
love that phrase and and i think he's
right because chess has been um
hand-in-hand with ai from the beginning
of the the whole field right so i think
every ai practitioner starting with
turing and claude shannon and all those
uh the sort of forefathers of of of of
the field um tried their hand at writing
a chess program uh i've got original
audition of claude shannon's first chess
program i think it was 1949 uh the the
original sort of uh uh paper and um they
all did that and turing famously wrote a
chess program that but all the computers
around there were obviously too slow to
run it so he had to run he had to be the
computer right so he literally i think
spent two or three days running his own
program by hand with pencil and paper
and playing playing a friend of his uh
with his chest program so
of course deep blue was a huge moment uh
beating caspar off um but actually when
that happened i remember that very very
vividly of course because it was you
know chess and computers and ai all the
things i loved and i was at college at
the time but i remember coming away from
that being more impressed by kasparov's
mind than i was by deep blue because
here was kasparov with his human mind
not only could he play chess more or
less to the same level as this brute of
a calculation machine um but of course
kasparov can do everything else humans
can do ride a bike talk many languages
do politics all the rest of the amazing
things that kasparov does
and so with the same brain yeah and and
yet deep blue
uh brilliant as it was at chess had been
hand coded for chess and um actually had
distilled the knowledge of chess grand
masters uh into into a cool program but
it couldn't do anything else like it
couldn't even play a strictly simpler
game like tic-tac-toe so um something to
me was missing from um
intelligence from that system that we
would regard as intelligence and i think
it was this idea of generality and and
also learning um so and that's also what
we tried to do out with alphago
you